Former Vice President
Mike Pence is now
speaking publicly
about his plans
to fight a subpoena from the U.S
Justice Department.
He weighed in twice today,
including some extended remarks
just a little while ago.
CNN justice correspondent
Jessica Schneider is joining us
with details.
So, Jessica, tell our viewers
what he said.
Well, Wolf, Mike Pence simply
simply didn't mince words today.
He explained how his team had di
with the Justice Department
before the subpoena was issued.
He said that his team was clear
with DOJ officials
that Pence would fight
any subpoena
on the grounds of the speech
or debate clause of the Constitu
And the former vice president to
really explained at length
how his duties as president of t
on January six.
And his view
precludes him
from talking about his actions
in discussions
leading up to and on that day.
Here he is
where the president said,
I'm going to fight the Biden DOJ
for me to appear
before the grand jury
because I believe it's unconstit
And it's unprecedented.
Never before in American history
vice president been summoned
to appear in court to testify
against the president
with whom they serve.
President Trump was wrong.
I had no right to overturn the e
And as I've said, I I've spoken
over the last two years
and written extensively about th
I think
President Trump's words were rec
They endangered me and my family
others at the Capitol.
And I'm not hesitated to say so.
That said, under the Constitutio
in this moment,
I believe my duty is also clear.
And that is the Constitution pro
an executive branch from summoni
into court for their legislative
Or duties.
And and on the day of January si
I was acting as president of the
presiding over a joint session
described in the Constitution it
And so I believe that
that speech and debate clause
of the Constitution actually
prohibits the executive branch
from compelling me to appear in
as the Constitution says,
or in any other place.
And we'll stand on that principl
we'll take that case
as far as it needs to go,
if needs be,
to the Supreme Court
of the United States.
I believe that would diminish
the privileges
enjoyed by any future vice presi
or be that Democrat or Republica
I simply will not do that.
Now, Pence did acknowledge
that he really has
talked about this before.
He wrote in his memoir
about his interactions
with former President Trump
in the days leading up to Januar
But he made clear
he will not comply with that sub
He will not testify under oath
about those same interactions.
Because as Pence sees it,
it would just set a bad preceden
But, Wolf,
this position really could mean
a long legal fight for the forme
president, just as he's consider
whether to announce a run for pr
something he hinted at in Iowa t
Wolf. Yes, he did.
All right.
Jessica Schneider, thank you ver
Let's get some more in all of th
Joining us now, CNN's
senior legal analyst Ellie Hoeni
He's also the author
of the brand new book,
very important book,
very timely book entitled Untouc
How Powerful People Get Away wit
Ali, congratulations. On the boo
Thanks once again.
Thanks very much for joining us.
Give us your reaction
to Pence's argument.
So, first of all, this is fascin
This is like a law school hypoth
come to life.
He actually does
have some substance in this argu
There's really two questions.
First of all, is he covered
by the speech and debate clause?
Constitution
says that members of Congress
can be covered.
Now, he was the president of the
in his role as vice president.
And the courts have construed
that broadly.
They've actually said it can app
to congressional staffers as wel
So I think it likely will apply
to Mike Pence,
the second part,
though, is
will his testimony
relate to his legislative duties
We just heard
Mike Pence
say everything I was doing
that day was in my capacity
as president of the Senate.
I think
counterargument will be to the e
you were involved in conversatio
with Donald Trump about crimes
that's not covered.
You think this fight
could go all the way up to the U
Supreme Court?
Absolutely.
And timing
is going to be so important here
It will start at the district co
which is the trial court level.
Whoever loses
there can automatically appeal
to the court of appeals.
Whoever loses
there will certainly try to take
to the Supreme Court.
And, of course,
it's up to the Supreme Court.
But this kind of case is tailor
made for them.
So when I hear that,
what does that do to the timelin
of this criminal investigation
of the former
president of the United States
by the Justice Department?
Special counsel.
Timing is so important here, Wol
We just heard about Mike Pence's
political considerations
but from DOJ, his perspective,
there is no way,
even if this case is super exped
that it gets through all those l
we just talked about in
anything less than four months
and probably more than that.
Is DOJ
willing and able to wait
for months
to get this testimony
and then incorporate it?
I mean, we're talking about
a four or five, six or more mont
if they're going to fight for th
You know, I assume they will fig
But correct me if I'm wrong.
Over the years,
the Justice Department
has had certain success
in fighting
these arguments about executive
over the years, right? Yeah, sur
Executive privilege
usually ends up going in DOJ's f
What's novel here?
The twist is Mike
Pence is using this obscure prov
from Article
one, the speech and debate claus
Now he's going to have a problem
And we just heard about this
because he has written
about a lot of these conversatio
in his book.
And so prosecutors
DOJ are going to argue, you've w
You've given up that. Right.
Once you talk about something pu
you no longer have those protect
You no longer have the legal rig
to keep it secret.
And in his book,
he wrote extensively
about those conversations.
It'll be an interesting legal ba
Thanks very much.